Transcriber: Enas J Alahmadi
المدقّق: Esraa Ibraheem
مرحبًا.
ما هو شعوركم إذا كنتم تمشون ورأيتم
شخصين يتناقشان واحتد بينهما النقاش،
فشتم أحدهما الآخر وقال له: "أنت سُورِي؟"
ما هو شعوركم أيضًا، إذا علمتم
أنه في مكانٍ ما على الكرة الأرضية،
يُنادى مجموعة من الناس
وهم أقلية ومستضعفون،
ويُقال لهم: السوريون.
احتج سكان منغوليا على تسمية الأشخاص
المصابين بمتلازمة داون بالمنغوليين.
ليس بسبب محبتهم للمصابين،
لكنهم شعروا أن هذه التسمية
تنتقص من قدرهم ومن كرامتهم،
لذلك احتجوا على هذه التسمية.
وبالفعل، وافقت الأمم المتحدة في أواخر
السبعينيات من القرن الماضي
على تغيير هذه التسمية، فأصبح
اسمها متلازمة الداون
عوضًا عن المنغوليين.
ونحن أيضًا يجب أن نحتج
ونرفض التنابذ بالألقاب مثل:
يا طويل، يا قصير، يا أهبل، يا مجنون،
يا ذا العيون الأربع، يا منغولي.
حسنًا، من يعرف بالموضوع سيناديهم داون،
لكن دعونا نرى، بماذا يحبون أن نناديهم:
"أنا اسمي حلا."
"أنا اسمي هالة الحُلوة."
"أنا اسمي طه."
"أنا عبدالله."
"أنا نور."
"أنا معاذ."
"أنا اسمي سِدرة."
"أنا بشار."
"أنا عبد الحليم."
"أنا هبة."
"أنا سماح."
"أنا علاء."
(تصفيق)
كما رأيتم، لهم أسماؤهم وهوياتهم
وكيانهم ووجودهم،
ويحبون أن نناديهم بأسمائهم.
إلى هنا الوضع تحت السيطرة،
لكن إذا عرف سكان منغوليا
أن كلمة منغولي تُقال عندنا كشتيمة،
عندها لا أعرف ما الذي قد يحصل.
الله يستر.
للأسف، هذه الشتيمة أصبحت
متبادلة بين الشباب والفتيات،
على أنها مصطلحٌ دارج
من المصطلحات الشبابية،
التي تجعلهم يبدون رائعين.
وبنفس الوقت، يوجد مجموعة من
الشباب والفتيات الذين يُفتَخر بهم،
يشاركون أطفال متلازمة داون وأهاليهم
بكل محبةٍ وكل احترام،
وفي كل لحظات الفرح والفخر،
وقصص النجاح الرائعة، خاصةً عندما يكونوا
شركاء في قصص النجاح.
بدأت القصة منذ سبعة وعشرين سنة.
عام 1990، كانوا مثل جميع الأهالي،
يودوّا بأن يكونوا أبًا وأمًّا.
وكانوا سُعداء جدًا بمولودهم الأول.
بدأت قصتنا عندما أصبحتُ أمًّا
لفتاةٍ جميلة اسمها هالة.
(تصفيق)
عندما علمنا أن هالة لديها صِبغي زائد،
لا أخفيكم أنه مثل جميع الأهالي
عندما يتلقوا خبرًا كهذا،
لم يكن أبدًا بالأمر السهل.
بالنسبة لي، كنت عندها في مرحلة النفّاس.
عندما عرف زوجي...
(تصفيق)
ظل يدور حول الدوار الموصِل إلى منزلنا،
دون أن يعرف أي طريقٍ مؤدي إليه.
بقيتُ مدة شهرٍ ونصف
أرى الأطباء يجيئون ويذهبون،
وفي كل مرة يقولون لي:
"يجب أن تسافري إلى الخارج،
فلقد تكلمنا بالموضوع مع أطِبّاء آخرين."
وعندما كنت أسألهم: "لماذا؟"
لم يجيبني أحد.
في الكثير من الأوقات، كنت أستيقظ ليلاً
فأسمع زوجي أسامة يدعي: "يا رب ساعدني"،
فأساله: "هل هناك خطبٌ ما؟"
فيرد عليّ: "كنتُ نائماً وأيقظتيني."
حتى جاء يومٌ قررت فيه أن هناكٌ خطبٌ ما،
ولابد أن أعرفه.
وبعد محاولات، أخبرني زوجي بالأمر.
كانت ردة فعلي غريبةً نوعًا ما.
قُلت:" ماذا إذن! ما المشكلة في ذلك!
فهالة بصحة جيدة وليس بها أي شيء."
فوضع يده على جبيني فوراً، وقال:
"أيُعقل ما تقولين! ألهذه الدرجة
حمى النفّاس سريعة؟"
بعد ساعةٍ تقريبًا، تجهزت ثم ذهبت إلى أُمي.
عندما رأيتها لم أتمالك نفسي فعانقتها
وانهمرت بالبكاء.
فقالت لي: "طالما عرفتي بالأمر،
ليس هناك وقتٌ للبكاء بل للعمل،
لابد أن نعمل."
عُدت إلى المنزل، وفي تلك الليلة
قال لي أسامة:
"لابد أن نرضى بالابتلاء والامتحان
الذي ابتلانا الله به،
ولابد أن نتعاون مع بعضنا البعض لمساعدتها،
ولنتمكن من تربيتها."
في تلك الليلة، تعاهدنا أنا وزوجي أن هالة
يجب أن تكون هالة في المجتمع.
كما تعاهدنا أننا سنجعلها تنشر هالةً
من الفرح والأمل والتفاؤل أينما ذهبت.
وعندما هممتُ بالنوم،
عادت إليّ ذكرياتٌ لأمرٍ حدث قريبًا،
لأنني كنت حينها طالبةٌ في الجامعة.
تذكرت عندما دعتني صديقتي شيرين إلى منزلها،
وأثناء إعدادها للقهوة،
بقيت لوحدي في الغرفة مع ايدي،
بالمناسبة، ايدي أيضًا لديه صِبغي زائد.
حينها خفتُ كثيرًا،
لأنني لم أعرف أي شيءٍ عنهم.
خفتُ لدرجة أنني دعوت أن تعود شيرين بسرعة.
عندما عادت شيرين ورأتني خائفة
قالت لي: "أتعلمين أن هذا صاحب أطيبِ قلب."
أيضًا تذكّرت فتىً لديه
متلازمة داون في الحارة،
كلما كان يخرج ليلعب مع الفتيان،
فإنهم كانوا يضربوه ويهينوه ويؤذونه.
وكنت أراه من بعيد وأشعر بالأسى نحوه،
ولكنني كنت خائفة ولا أعرف كيف أساعده،
لأنني لم أكن أعرف ما الذي يتوجب عليّ فعله.
ظلّت هذه الذكريات تراودني حتى غلبني النوم.
في الحقيقة، بفضل صدق وإرادة زوجي،
ومساعدته لي ولهالة،
استطعت الوصول إلى هذا المكان.
(تصفيق)
أول شيءٍ قمنا به هو الذهاب إلى فرنسا
من أجل عمل تحليلٍ للصِبغات،
للتأكد بعدم حملنا لمتلازمة داون.
أخبرني الطبيب هناك جملةً علقت في ذهني.
(تتحدث باللغة الفرنسية)
قال لي: "الحب والاهتمام هما
العلاج الوحيد لهذه الحالات."
بالفعل، جعلنا من هذه الجملة
عنوانًا لنا أنا وأسامة،
لنتمكّن من التعامل مع هالة وتطويرها.
جملةٌ أخرى أخبرني إياها أخصائيٌ بمِصر،
قال لي: "العمر الذهبي لأبنائكم،
هو أول سبع سنوات من أعمارهم.
اجتهدوا في تربيتهم خلالها،
فترتاحوا كثيرًا عند كبرهم."
هذه الجملة أيضًا جعلناها عنوانًا للعمل
الدؤوب في التعامل مع هالة وصديقاتها،
وكنت أُخبر بها كل أمٍ وأبٍ جديدان
لديهما أبناء بنفس حالة هالة.
هناك جملةٌ أخرى، قرأتها في قصةٍ لأم
أنشأت مركزًا كبيرًا جدًا من أجل ابنها،
قالت: "نحن نحبهم وراضون بهم كما هم،
من لا يستطيع أن يحبهم،
فإن تلك مشكلته وليست مشكلتنا."
وضعت تلك الجملة نصب عيني،
لأتخطى أي موقفٍ أو نظرةٍ أو أي شيءٍ
من الممكن أن يعيق تقدمنا أو يثبط همتنا.
بعد سنةٍ وشهر، أصبحت أمًا للمرة الثانية
لابني سمير.
سمير هو الأخ الحنون والمدرب المجهول لهالة.
عندما ساعدت سميرًا في المشي،
تعلمت هالة المشي أيضًا.
وعندما دربتُ سميرًا على النظافة الشخصية،
نجحت هالة أيضًا في ذلك.
وعندما أصبح سميرٌ مستعدًا لدخول الروضة،
دخلت هالة أيضًا الروضة معه.
وهكذا كان هذا الطفل يدرب أخته دون أن يعلم.
الآن أصبح هذا الطفل طبيباً،
والآن أصبحت من تقوم بتلك المهمة،
هي أختها الصغرى سنا.
(تصفيق)
كانت توجدة فتاةٌ صغيرةٌ
في العائلة اسمها فرح.
فرح تصغُر هالة بسنتين.
كانت تصّر على أخذ هالة معها
في أي مكانٍ تذهب إليه.
وهكذا، أصبحت لهالة حياتها
الاجتماعية الخاصة،
وصديقات فرح أصبحن صديقاتٍ لهالة.
تزوج العديد من تلك الفتيات،
وأصبحن طبيباتٍ ومهندساتٍ،
ومازلن يأخذن هالة في كل مكانٍ يذهبن إليه،
حتى فرح أصبحت طبيبة.
في كثيرٍ من الأوقات، عندما نخرج أنا وهالة
لنتنزه، تُسلم هالة على الكثير من الأشخاص
فلقد أصبحت تعرف أُناسًا أكثر مني.
يدلنا هذا على أنه عندما يكون
المجتمع الصغير داعم ومساند لأبنائنا،
فإن ذلك يريح الأهالي ويجعل الأبناء
ينتقلون إلى المجتمع الكبير،
بكل ثقة وبلا خوف.
في تلك الفترة، كنت أنا وخمس أمهات لأبناء
حالتهم مثل هالة - أي لديهم صِبغي زائد -
نجتمع في منزلي.
بحيث تأتينا أخصائيةٌ من الشام،
وتنظم لنا برنامجًا لنعمل عليه،
وبعد شهر تأتينا مرة أخرى لترى
مدى تطورنا وعملنا على البرنامج.
واستمررنا على هذا الحال تقريبًا
لمدة سنةٍ أو سنةٍ ونصف.
بعد ذلك، شعرت بأن الأمر لن يستمر طويلًا،
لذلك لابد أن نكوّن لنا كيانًا خاصًا.
في تلك الفترة، لم يكن هناك أي
جمعيةٍ متخصصةٍ بحالات متلازمة داون.
فانتسبت لإحدى الجمعيات،
وما زالت هذه الجمعية حتى هذه اللحظة
تساعدنا وتدعمنا كأمهات،
لأنها كانت مؤمنة بقضيتنا.
ما حدث هو أننا أخذنا أحد فصول
الروضة التابعة للجمعية،
فاجتهدنا بالعمل عليه وتزيينه،
حتى أصبح أجمل فصلٍ في حمص.
كنا سعيداتٍ جدًا حينها،
وشعرنا أن كل أمورنا قد تحسّنت،
وبدأنا العمل مع أبنائنا بكل حماسة.
فجأةً، جاءنا أمرٌ بإغلاق الفصل
من وزارة التربية والتعليم،
والسبب هو أن أحد الأهالي قد اشتكى
بأن ابنه يرتعش رعباً عند رؤية أبنائنا.
أُغلق الفصل وحينها بدأت معاناتنا الحقيقية.
كان لابد أن نجد مكانًا، ليكون لنا كيانًا.
كنا نستأجر في كل مرة غرفةً
مع دورة مياه لمدة ستة أشهر.
إذا انتهى عقد الإيجار،
ورفض صاحب السكن أن نمدد المدة،
فكنا نخرج مع أبنائنا وأمتعتنا
لنبحث عن مكانٍ جديدٍ.
في ذلك الوقت، وصل عددنا إلى 11 طفل.
في تلك الأثناء، كانت رئيسة الجمعية
تقدم معروضات استرحام إلى الوزارة،
ولكن للأسف كانت كلها تُقابل بالرفض.
استمررنا لما يقارب السنتين
ننتقل من مسكنٍ إلى آخر،
تقريباً انتقلنا إلى 3 مساكن،
وفي عام 2000، وافقت الوزارة
على إعطائنا رخصة لافتتاح مركز لأبنائنا.
وفعلاً افُتتح المركز، وكان أول وأكبر تجمع
لذوي متلازمة داون في سوريا بأكملها.
(تصفيق)
كنا نعمل في المركز على منهجٍ
وضعته مديرة الشؤون الاجتماعية والعمل،
ولكننا أضفنا إليه شيئًا جميلًا،
ألا وهو لمستنا الخاصة كأمهات.
في الواقع، لو أن كل الأهالي يربون أبنائهم،
بنفس الطريقة التي عملنا
على تربية أبنائنا بها،
كنتم سترون جيلًا مذهلًا.
نجح أبناؤنا وكل من في المركز،
لأننا كنا مجموعة أمهاتٍ مؤمناتٍ
بقدرات أبنائنا.
لم يكن أبناؤنا ناجحين في المركز فقط،
بل كانوا أبطالًا في الأولمبياد.
كنا نأخذهم إلى الملعب مرتين في الأسبوع،
فكان كل من يرانا يقول:
"جميلٌ أنكم تُخرجوهم ليتسلّوا."
لكنهم لم يكونوا يعرفوا أبدًا،
بأننا كنا نعمل على مشروع "صناعة أبطال".
استمررنا في ذلك، وكان أبناؤنا يفوزا
ببطولات لم يكن العالم يعرف عنها كثيرًا.
كانوا أبطالًا في كرة السلة وكرة الريشة
والسباحة وألعاب القوى وكل أنواع الألعاب.
وفي عام 2010، أُقيمت الدورة الإقليمية
السابعة للأولمبياد الخاص في سوريا،
والذي شاركت فيها كل الدول العربية،
حينها عُرفت بطولات أبنائنا.
في الحقيقة، كان الأولمبياد الخاص نقطة تحول
رائعة في حياة أبنائنا وحياة أهاليهم.
لم ينجح أبناؤنا في هذا المجال فقط،
بل نجحوا في مجالاتٍ أخرى أيضًا.
عندما عدنا أنا وزوجي من الشارقة،
بحيث حضرنا هناك مؤتمرًا
لتأهيل وتشغيل ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصة.
عدنا بكل حماسة، وبالفعل تم تشغيل
خمسة من أبنائنا.
عمل سعدٌ ومعاذٌ في معملٍ للملابس،
أما هبة وهالة وزينة فقد عملوا
في محلٍ لبيع الملابس.
كانوا يعرفون جيدًا بأن (S) تعني صغير،
وبأن (M) تعني وسط،
وبأن (L) تعني كبير.
كما كانوا مدركين بأن 12 قطعة تعادل دستة،
وبأن 24 قطعة تعادل صندوقًا كبيرًا.
لا أستطيع أن أصف لكم شعورهم،
عند وقوف مسرحٍ كامل...
أو دعوني أخبركم عند استلامهم أول راتب.
كان شعورهم لا يُوصف عند استلامهم أول راتب،
بحيث شعروا أنهم لم يعودوا
عالةً على المجتمع.
وأيضًا كان شعورًا لا يوصف،
عندما وقف كل من في المسرح
ليُصفق لبطلة أولمبياد... راقصة بالية
لديها صِبغي زائد،
ألا وهي هالة.
في نفس الوقت، عندما كنتُ أعرض
رسمات هالة على الناس، كانوا يسألونني:
"أحقًا رسمتها هالة بنفسها؟
وبدون أي مساعدة؟"
وفي يومٍ ما...
أظن أنني أخطات ولكن لا عليكم...
(تصفيق)
وفي يومٍ ما، نظمتُ لها معرضاً
لعرض رسومتها الخمسة والأربعين،
وكان أول معرضٍ يُقام في حمص
لفتاة لديها صِبغي زائد،
حتى أن الشارع قد أُغلق
من كثرة الزائرين للمعرض.
"انتبه على الكاميرا حتى لا تُكسر!"
هي جملةٌ قد نسمعها من أي شخصٍ
يرى الكاميرا في أيدي أبنائه.
لكننا لم نفعل ذلك.
عندما قام أحد أبنائنا بالتقاط
صورةٍ باستخدام الكاميرا،
أخذنا الصورة وحمضّناها.
- في تلك الفترة كان هناك
ما يُسمى بـ "تحميض الأفلام" -
وعندما ظهرت الصورة كانت جميلةً جدًا
وبتفاصيلٍ رائعة.
حينها قررنا إقامة معرض للتصوير الضوئي،
لنعرض فيه قصص نجاحٍ جديدة.
وبالفعل أُقيم آخر معرضٍ لنا في عام 2016.
في الحقيقة، تغيّرت نظرة مجتمعٍ كاملٍ،
بفضل بطولات وإنجازات أبنائنا.
في كثيرٍ من الأحيان، يأتينا أُناسٌ يعرّفون
عن أنفسهم عن طريق معرفتهم لأبنائنا،
"أنا جارٌ لمعاذ."
"صديقي أخٌ لصديق طه."
"أختي صديقة أخت هبة."
علمتني هالة الصبر.
علمتني أن أصبر على الابتلاء.
علمتني أن أصبر على كل الامتحانات
التي نمر بها.
علمتني الفخر، علمتني أن أفخر بها
وبنفسي وبزوجي وبأبنائي وبكل شيءٍ فعلناه.
علمتني هالة معنى الحب الحقيقي بدون مقابل.
أٌيعقل أن زيادة الصِبغي في أجسامهم،
يجعلهم جميلين لهذه الدرجة!
أعدكم أني سأستمر في العمل معكم،
لطالما أملك القدرة على ذلك.
أود أن أخبركم بشيء،
يستحق ذوي الصبغي الزائد،
أن نوليّهم اهتمامًا أكبر وحبًا أكثر
لقلوبهم التي تحمل حنانًا أكثر.
ودعونا جميعًا نناديهم باسمائهم،
تمامًا كالأشخاص الذين يحبونهم.
(تصفيق)